pete davidson has a new movie coming out
by famed director
judd apatow remember judd apatow you
remember like remember the early 2000s
remember super bad he fell off hard
yeah tell you something there was a
vacuum
in america for like 10 years it was no
good comedy
there was no good nothing this was the
postdane cook era
and it was it was a lawless land where
judd apatow was able to
make the same mediocre movie like 10
times and
get cash money for it
glad he's back was his downfall when he
did that movie with amy schumer who by
the way does frank cooking shows now
he was falling apart before that i think
yeah
yeah he hasn't really had a a home run
in a long time
we want to watch a trailer for his new
movie the king of staten island oh
i guess
i like your tattoos what are those
numbers on your arm oh
i hope it's for a [ __ ] crap somewhere
in front of me
that's uh the date my dad died he was a
fireman died in a fire
17 years ago wait so is this the pete
davidson story
plucked from the headline is this pete
davidson in the pete davidson story
plucked from the headlands is this the p
davidson biopic
yes biopic or whatever you pronounce it
we are going to pluck this from the
headlines so is this partial it's gonna
be
his life but not his life right
isn't this like one of the lowest forms
of a film you can make like isn't this
the kind of movie they make for a rapper
or or right yeah like this is a 50 cent
type
thing like an eminem type thing really
glad that judd apatow is making comedies
about
9 11. so far laugh right
so he wants to make like an eight mile
or like his get rich or die trying
is that right right my dad died he was a
fireman
dying of fire
this movie's gonna be hilarious it
wasn't the joke oh that was just the sad
part oh
well we're off to a good start in this
comedy film
oh my name's pete davidson lake dead oh
i used to have
instead of a dad i just had a plaque i
could visit every year
we also i don't know jim norton was
writing this movie
nate my dad died see like he's taking so
what's happening is like
he's taking the power from it like you
know there's pain
yeah no no so like they're smoking weed
i hate this
mike he's speaking truth to power
so what's happening is this right like
he's
it's something tragic but he's like bro
you can make fun of me for it i know
i know what he's trying to do
news man it's tattoos and weed stuff
it's pretty cool
because you know p davidson wanted to
try some new stuff something new
comedy
it's it's this weird like he wants to be
this like deep meaningful
tortured guy right he's torturing me all
right
and it's so great it's pretty [ __ ]
crap
just be funny like you know why people
remember
some of some other guys as like these
tortured guys because
they were funny like chris farley chris
farley didn't go around going like god
damn i'm so dark and tortured no he
didn't cloak and [ __ ] prostitutes
the reason he's interesting to go back
and study is because like he's
he tried to hold it together he was a
show business professional who would
show up to the tonight show because he
said he'd be there
and he'd look like [ __ ] and you could go
back and study those and go
oh was that one of his bad days look
he's barely holding it together
but chris farley wasn't going oh man i'm
so
tragic dude let's talk about my tragic
life
man he would come in and do his wacky
dances
and he'd [ __ ] put on a show and then
he'd leave and go do speed balls and
almost die every night
like this guy is just too it's
too on the nose it's like god man i'm so
tortured
us funny guys man we're so dark and
tortured and it's like
you're you're selling it so hard that
you're like god this is crap you're so
good
well uh i i say i do say it all the time
but it's like
the the thing with pete davidson that
really bothers me
is he's trying to be a rock star and a
comic and i don't think you could be
both
you know yeah but that's yeah and the
ones that
were rock star and comics you don't know
about it
until after they're dead it's like again
like the chris farley's and stuff i
don't even think anyone really knew
what a rock star he was until he died
and people were like oh yeah he was
slamming heroin and doing hookers and
[ __ ] partying and
you know like they kept that [ __ ] kind
of quiet it wasn't meant to be his
persona
it was how they were this guy is like
selling the persona of it
can marissa thomas still get it though
yeah of course right where's the tomato
yeah and they probably had to make her
look
you know a little fugly well he's there
from staten island
that's true you just if you step into
staten island you'll magically become
uglier
see get tattooed a cat on the dude who
wrote this movie pete davidson's friends
in his basement
yes they wrote they tattooed the script
on his back
spielberg hey pete check it out i'm
[ __ ] your mom what do you think huh
nah that's crazy ah but what do i know
bill burst [ __ ] plowing or
plowing your mom in the house that you
live in with her while and then doing
his podcast on monday
why does bill burr look like a
registered sex offender in this too
what's up with that guy you dated 17
years is a [ __ ] bill bird looks like
he's about to shoot
he's about to shrink billboard looks
like
like like the way you'd show up to an
audition
thinking you're supposed to look for an
80s firefighter
yeah like this movie calls for a 80s
firefighter
and you show up like yeah i thought this
looked good right
are you dating 17 years as a fireman
just like that you don't think that's
weird
you're too old to give a [ __ ] who your
mom dates bro like
this movie's so dumb like what
you're too old to give you oh you're not
over dad
what's the point of this movie i'm
waiting for the comedy this is judd
apatow this is a comedy right
break
oh no oh god i just looked it up
yes yes the three writers
who were the writers was pete davidson
shout out patel who's the third
dave cyrus
the guy we were with at the [ __ ]
comedy fight club dave cyrus yeah
uh but to be fair he's the third guy on
there which means this is mostly pete
davidson and john apatow no
no no look i like yeah dave dave's
probably the guy that was brought in
and they were like could you do anything
to punch this up
please help us punch this up but i will
not give him a reprieve on this okay
i like him that's fair no i'm not
defending it i'm just saying that
i could that's he probably was brought
in though like this thing
really is bad can you make it funny
a stupid chemist in it and then what do
you think uh
pete what do you think maybe you could
become a firefighter i don't like your
pop
what do you think huh you risk your life
every day uh running up buildings saving
a bunch of
babies you make like a hot 32 000 a year
what do you say pete
yeah but what do i know the whole movie
just
beat this should i could if what if he's
he's is he actually playing pete
davidson in this movie
because that would be even better if the
movie's like should i quit saturday
night live
to make 35 000 a year as a
new york city firefighter the whole
movie is just him
hanging out what if this really is what
if that really is just steve buscemi in
the movie
and he's like hey i'm talking i had to
find the only guy who's done both
and the only other guy i know on the
planet it's like letterman asking for
carson for advice
you're the only guy i know that's been
both a firefighter and a movie star
which one should i do steve
and steve buscemi's like i don't know
kid i mean i like acting's pretty cool
i got to be on the surprise i was in the
boardwalk empire
[Laughter]
i mean kid i would stick with the acting
you get to bang actresses and
it's way less it's being a firefighter
kind of sucks to be honest
and that's the end of the movie the end
of the movie is him hanging out with
bill burns steve buscemi
and bill bird going yeah no i'm just
hanging around the firefighters because
i'm uh you know i got a roll coming up
i've just been following him around this
whole movie is bill burr is banging pete
davidson's mom
in real life it's a documentary
bill burr is following firefighters
around for a role
because they're going to make a a
live-action film version of
uh dennis leary's the job dennis leary's
rescued me
but bill burr is gonna play the lead
role in it so he's learning how to be a
firefighter
and this whole movie ends with them just
making fun of firefighters at a diner
i gotta tell my mom you tried to drown
me to the background pool you're like
[ __ ] eight feet tall
did they film this movie in [ __ ]
carl's house from aqua team
staten island i mean they probably
filmed it in staten island which
that looks like staten island that
definitely looks like staten island or
long island